こんにちははじめ社長です
おっ
ちょっとでかい声を出すとバレるのでちょっと静かに行きますえ私の除雪を今ですね
愛知県にある
幸田町立高た中学校に来ております
で今回何をしようかといいますとあの
金融させていただきたいと思います
この通学子さんがですね直別に潜入の許可を下さったので
中学校に潜入できるそうそうないと思うんでこうた中学校の皆さんを驚かせに私今回
愛知県まで行ってまいります今からちょっと授業中のあるクラスに突撃しに行くんです
けども
ほっそい侵入して9
に入って出てきたらどんだけを取れてくれるのかっていうサプライズ的なことをやって
いきたいとおもいます
自分のことを言う意地の悪いわけじゃないんですけど知ってる人が突然ず行中に貼って
できたらメッチャクチャけんしょん上がると思うんで羨ましいですね
ちょっとほんとどうなるか反応わかんないんですけど突然中学校の授業中に
肇社長が
飛び出して来たらどういう反応するのか見ていきたいとおもいます
でない子
かわいい
ああああああああ
[音楽]
はいというわけで猛追業が迫っているので注げる
ターゲット見通しに寝具していこうと思います
いきましょう
ん
あれ
根占
[音楽]
voodoo
あああああどうよ
[音楽]
うわぁ
あああああ
イェーイウーウー
ua re ある
どうやってみよだまさ寺のこっそり潜入してくるなぁをができません
me
car
この部分は全校集会あるんですよ
これで僕また現れるん
それで他のテーパさんやみんな内緒にしてるから
このクラスのみんな俺が遺骨はない数字で相手を上げるなんとかうまくいったみたい
です
ええええええ
これ jan
pou dou dou
air
パワー
はいど望み出会うっていうのがライフ5位
oppo のやるだろう
塩梅だ
ブービー22時0分0厘0
カラー白ソニー
どっ如意い
まず必要は皆さんへで汽笛をこそ
を入れる
スペシャルゲスト0
はじめしゃちょー方便
[拍手]
te na
voodoo
パーティー re
tha みなさん
goo
[拍手]
[音楽]
voodoo
ああ皆さんこんにちは者はたぁー
僕は初めて見てい阿部
ウェアー
受け皿をいただき知ってみましょうせーのアーマー0
あ気持ちありがとうございます編集卑怯なんですけども参りセピという教材を使って皆
さんと
ある勉強したいことです遊び the 遊べじゃない勉強です
さあじゃまずスマイル準備配りません
いって言った
それ相撲汁というためインターできるやつなんですけども
問題を解くと a 班っていうかな t 版っていうでよくできたかできないかでいい
んですけども
今日は皆さんが全員
a 判定が出るまで帰れませ
いうわけである
て開いてみましょう9
くださいで全部で午後あるのでみなさんぜひ1.2
やってみましょうはいでは行きます
4位
じゃぁぁぁ
[音楽]
ああああああ
あっているん
とったら俺一門と言った後に
解説で見れるので答え合わせしたとそれでどうやって書けばいいかもが出てくるん
だろう
これを参考に頑張ってみてください天から教えることはない
じゃあパッケージでしょはーい
ています
俺はいつ終わるか分からんですよ
[音楽]
てみたいですね
me
a 46所はい
阿部はたさに
これはやばいぞもられないちなみに問題が整形しても1分以内に留めてなかったらダメ
になってなるべく s フィードを大事なんですね
すって
てみてくださいはいもう1回いきましょうねー
全員0取るまで帰れませんと言ったんですが私はさんが強い姿勢ではありません
10人入ったら割りましょう
月あと30分
さあ頑張りましょういきますよ良いんだぞ
[音楽]
もうさぁみんなに教えたっ
東ヨナがスピードが命だ覚えてくださいはい
ムースが米飯てるんでしょ
はいもう2
随時ねー受領
ああああああ
ございました
皆さん0あああああ今日はありがとうございました
あああ
入って今日は本当に先生として2軍落ちたんですけども
前でテレビいかがだったでしょうか低床3人くらい時間待つディンプルなろうかです
けども
女たちが10人以上
になりましたそしてこの踏まえの風味がべくのもぽっく者数3名の風況だけではなく
音楽美術体育技術家庭の4漁協も含まれて9教科部
それだけで勉強てきまーぬー日々の集約シュッに中間テスト政策を進めている
います
[音楽]
ブービー14エロさティっは
是非資料請求してみてください詳しい内容はどんなダイヤにあります
youtube さっきですね村中学生がやってた問題も車増えてみたんですけども
1問も解けませんでした
[音楽]
me
バッハ